people of turkey and Syria in response
to the ongoing humanitarian crisis there
and we continue to take steps to do so
I'm sure you all saw during the Super
Bowl to during the Super Bowl yesterday
to donate to earthquake relief efforts
and I want to point out some resources
just for that there's a page on USA AIDS
has a list where they have a list of
vetted organizations responding to this
crisis should individuals want to
contribute you can find that at
cidi.org in Turkey our Urban search and
rescue teams continue their efforts
assisting in live rescues over the
weekend we also continue to support the
Turkish teams on the ground U.S military
helicopters are providing critical lift
for U.S and international responders our
teams also continue to conduct
structural damage assessments of
buildings with the hope of being able to
clear as many as possible today they
have assessed more than 5 500 buildings
allowing thousands of people who are
currently displaced to be able to return
home
in Syria cross-border age shipments have
increased yesterday a fourth U.N Convoy
of 10 trucks from a U.S supported
humanitarian partner successfully
crossed into Syria from turkey that
brings the total to 52 U.N trucks but
more needs to be done it's critical for
the security Council to authorize two
additional Crossings to help deliver
life-saving assistance we cannot delay
any longer again I want to emphasize
that any U.S or International sanctions
include exemptions for humanitarian
medical food and other Aid and one last
thing before I turn it over to the
Admiral I just wanted to make sure we
addressed this from the White House I
know there have been questions and and
concerns about this but there is no
again no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns again there is no
indication of aliens or terrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
wanted to make sure that the American
people knew that all of you knew that
and it was important for us to say that
from here because we've been hearing a
lot about it
um I I I'm not
would you tell us I'm just you know I
loved E.T the movie but I'm just gonna
leave it there
um
with that with all seriousness I know
there's a lot of questions about uh the
flying objects Admiral John Kirby is
here with us today and he's going to
have a Topper a couple things to say at
the top about it and then take your
questions okay
[Music]
it's my job easy
I do have uh quite a few comments here
at the top so I do I hope that you'll
just uh bear with me and then be happy
to take whatever questions you uh you
might have
so I'd like to begin today by updating
you on our efforts to recover the debris
of several objects that the United
States Air Force shot down over the last
few days as well as that of the Spy
balloon belonging to the People's
Republic of China
and I'd like to put into some context
for you how we have worked and are still
working to better understand the issue
of high altitude low speed craft
now let me start with a Chinese program
when President Biden came into office he
directed the U.S intelligence Community
to do a broad assessment of Chinese
intelligence capabilities and to assure
and to ensure that we were working to
detect and to protect against them
I think for reasons that you will all
understand we cannot publicly go into
many details about how we discover uh
and counteract foreign intelligence
collection efforts because much of what
we have done and are doing is of course
sensitive
but we were able to determine that China
has a high altitude balloon program for
intelligence collection that's connected
to the people's Liberation Army
it was operating during the previous
administration but they did not detect
it
we detected it we tracked it
and we have been carefully studying it
to learn as much as we can
we know that these PRC surveillance
balloons have crossed over dozens of
countries on multiple continents around
the world
including some of our closest allies and
partners
we assessed that at this time these
balloons have provided limited additive
capabilities to the prc's other
intelligence platforms
used over the United States
but in the future if the PRC continues
to advance this technology it certainly
could become more valuable to them
the President also instructed the
intelligence Community to take a broad
look at the phenomenon of unidentified
aerial objects
indeed President Biden conducted the
first ever daily intelligence briefing
session devoted to this phenomenon back
in June of 2021
he was brief that this is not just an
issue for the United States but one for
the rest of the world and as I said our
friends and our partners are dealing
with this as well
we worked on a bipartisan basis to stand
up in office at the Pentagon to study
this
in partnership with the intelligence
Community academic institutions and the
private sector
these unidentified aerial phenomena have
been reported for many years without
explanation or deep examination by the
government
President Biden has changed all that
we are finally trying to understand them
better
now in light of the Chinese balloon
program and this recent incursion into
our airspace
the United States and Canada through
NORAD have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspace including
enhancing our radar capabilities which
as the commander of North Common NORAD
General van hurk said just last night
May at least partially explain the
increase in the objects that have been
detected
slow moving objects at high altitude
with a small radar cross section are
difficult to detect on radar even
objects the size of a the Chinese Bible
which had a payload the size of roughly
three school buses were not picked up by
previous administrations or other
countries
we also know that a range of entities
including countries companies research
and academic organizations operate
objects at these altitudes for purposes
that are not nefarious at all including
scientific research
that said because we have not yet been
able to definitely definitively assess
what these most recent objects are
we acted out of an abundance of caution
to protect the security our security our
interest and flight safety
in Saturday's case
we acted in consultation with the
Canadian government the president
speaking personally with the with prime
minister Trudeau
the Spy balloon was of course different
because we knew precisely where that was
as we have said
we do not assess that these most recent
objects posed any direct threat to
people on the ground and we are laser
focused on confirming their nature and
purpose including through intensive
efforts to collect debris in the remote
locations where they have fallen
in each instance we have followed the
same basic course
we assessed whether they posed any
kinetic threat to people on the ground
they did not
we assessed whether they were sending
any communication signals
we detected none
we looked to see whether they were
maneuvering or had any propulsion
capabilities
we saw no signs of that
and we made sure to determine whether or
not they were manned
they were not
we did however assess that their
altitudes were considerably lower than
the Chinese high altitude balloon and
did pose a threat to civilian commercial
air traffic
and while we have no specific reason to
suspect that they were conducting
surveillance of any kind we couldn't
rule that out
that is why the president at the
recommendation of the Secretary of
Defense the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff and the north North com NORAD
Commander gave the order to shoot them
down
these missions were completed
successfully and safely efforts are
actively underway right now at all sites
to find what is left of those objects so
that we can better understand and
communicate with the American people
what they are
I think it's important to remind the
objects in Alaska and Canada are in
pre-remote Terrain
ice and Wilderness all of that making it
difficult to find them in winter weather
the object over Lake Huron Now lies in
what is probably very deep water
so outside of recovery operations what
are we doing
well first
We are continuing to monitor
there are no active tracks today
but the professionals at Nord will
continue to do their important work
secondly we are Consulting with allies
and partners on the challenge of
identified aerial phenomenon
and how we can all work together
to deal with that challenge
the president has directed the secretary
of state Secretary of Defense
and the Director of National
Intelligence to engage with their
relevant counterparts to share
information and to try to gain their
perspectives as well again this is an
issue that affects everybody around the
world
third we will continue to brief members
of Congress and relevant State
leadership on what we are doing and what
we learn president has made this a very
top priority
we have over the course of just the last
few days and certainly over the course
of last week reached out to inform and
brief members of Congress and relevant
State governors of the operations that
we were conducting and other recovery
operations that are underway we've also
kept Congress briefed generally on this
issue of Chinese surveillance balloons
including classified briefings last
August
and last week Administration officials
provided classified briefings for all
senators and all members of the House of
Representatives on the PRC surveillance
balloon we fully expect and anticipate
and support
the ability to continue these briefings
in the days ahead
and fourth
the president through his National
Security advisor has today directed an
interagency team to study the broader
policy implications for detection
analysis and disposition of unidentified
aerial objects that pose either safety
or security risks every element of the
government will redouble their efforts
to understand and mitigate these events
and I'm happy to take some questions
um John if the objects don't pose a
military threat and they don't pose a
threat to anybody on the ground why
shoot them down particularly because the
military has uh is routinely monitoring
radar you know radar blips I kind of
covered that in the opening statement
um two real reasons here
first there was a very real potential
risk to civilian air traffic
the ones shut down on Saturday I'm sorry
uh yesterday uh was about twenty
thousand feet and the two shut down
Friday and Saturday were at about 40 000
feet and as you know transcontinental
air traffic is roughly around thirty
thousand feet it depends of course on on
weather and so uh because we assessed
that they weren't manned and weren't
being controlled
uh therefore left to atmospheric
conditions
um the the real risk to safety of flight
was was a problem the second purpose and
I talked about this earlier too was even
though we had no indications
that any of these three objects were
surveilling we couldn't rule that out
and so there you know you want to err on
the side of safety here in terms of
protecting our national security
interests and the fact that these
objects could have and uh and likely did
at some point in their path uh Transit
over you know potential military sites
of ours or sensitive sites so again out
of an abundance of caution for those two
reasons the president with the
recommendation of his military leaders
directed them to be taken down because
it's so
um
I think as transparent as we can be I
won't speak for the president's uh
personal uh speaking schedule but I mean
he has been deeply engaged in uh every
one of these decisions he's been kept
informed including as of this morning on
what's going on with recovery efforts
um and uh and he's very much staying on
top of the issue and uh and directing
his team
to make sure we are properly Consulting
and briefing not just members of
Congress but State leaders as well and
of course you know we're also doing what
we can in the in the public sphere
wait a second sir excuse me
thank you John
what is the president's standard going
to be going forward about when he orders
an unidentified object shot down it's it
comes down to
one simple formulation and that's if at
the recommendation of his military
leaders he believes that the Safety and
Security of the United States the Safety
and Security of the American people his
prime responsibility warrant that kind
of a decision so it's possible we could
see these shoot Downs on a regular basis
like we saw over the weekend I don't
think it's useful for me to get ahead of
where we are right now the president
will always side on preserving and
protecting the Safety and Security of
the American people you said we're not
applying any surveillance balloons over
China are we flying any other kind of
surveillance craft routinely over China
we are not flying surveillance balloons
over China and I'm not aware of any
other craft that we're flying over into
Chinese airspace and then finally can
you tell us anything more about this
octagonal object how big was it we're
still trying to assess uh what what that
was I'm not gonna get into a description
I've seen the Press reports about what
would it look like
um I I think we all need to be humble
here in in terms of what our ability is
to positively identify stuff from
fighter aircrafts that are going several
hundred miles an hour past essentially
in terms of relative motion a stationary
object
um that was not very big
um so we don't know what this exactly
looked like and again we're still not
sure exactly what what it what the
purpose of it was or who owned it but we
we hope to be able to find out more once
we can recover debris from that one and
from the other two as well
um just a few minutes ago prime minister
Trudeau said that there's some sort of
pattern to the objects over the last few
days is that something you could
elaborate on what sort of pattern the
White House has seen I'm not familiar
with the prime minister's comments so I
I don't know if I uh if I should take a
swing at that I would just tell you that
going back to what I said before
these objects were not being maneuvered
they did not appear to have any
self-propulsion
so the likely hypothesis is that they
were being moved by the prevailing winds
and maybe perhaps that's what the prime
minister is talking about I don't want
to speak for him but certainly
um as the prevailing winds particularly
at that altitude go west to east across
the North American
airspace I mean there was a general
common movement in in that regard you
spoke at the top about kind of
reassessing radar given what happened
with with the initial balloon can you
give us a sense can we expect uh should
we assume that this is the the regular
number of these objects over the United
States that they've always been there
and they just have been looked at the
same way or is there any reason to
expect that this is this is more than
usual that are flying so two thoughts
there I mean I I think um
I think we can all
get our heads around the fact that
um that there are sometimes
things floating at high altitudes for
various purposes as I said scientific
research weather weather balloons uh all
manner of uh of uh of innocuous craft uh
can can be Aloft at high altitudes I
don't think that that's necessarily
unusual here it's difficult for for me
to say exactly what you can expect going
forward
one of the reasons that we think we're
seeing more is because we're looking for
more as you heard uh General van hurt
mentioned last night they have
they have modified the filters and the
gains as we call it of the of the radar
capabilities to look more
discreetly at high altitude small radar
cross section and low speed objects and
so if you do that and anybody that's
operated a radar will know you can set
you can set the parameters and if you
set the parameters in such a way that to
look for a certain something it's more
likely that you're going to find a
certain something
and given all you've discussed during
the action of the administration of
taking and what people have learned
Chinese spy balloon this year and
previous years these unidentified
objects that we shoot down they might
have a question uh when it comes to
these higher altitudes our America's
borders secure
the president takes as I said earlier he
takes our national security uh extremely
seriously he has no higher
responsibility than the Safety and
Security of the American people and I
don't think you need to look any further
quite frankly than the decisions he's
made in just the last week to 10 days to
evidence that but it feels like he's
plugging holes like these are
vulnerabilities that we are discovering
in real time you're making an assumption
there that I don't know that the I don't
know that the analysis will actually
Bear out
get Brian in the back thank you very
much
the president gave the order to shoot
down the average over Lake Huron
yesterday where was he what kind of
information did he have when he gave
that order what was brief to him and and
how did he anticipate the outcome of
that he was here in the white house he
was kept constantly informed by uh by
his National Security team and certainly
by the military
um uh he made that decision I don't
couldn't give you the exact time on the
clock but it was uh I believe uh mid to
late morning
um and uh and then it was executed in
the in the afternoon
where they're continuously in place in
case there was a reaction from a foreign
government in reaction to shooting that
object down
yesterday the one yesterday yeah well it
was shot over I mean it was shot over
Lake Huron and landed in what we believe
to be the Canadian side of the lake
um so we were obviously in constant
communication and consultation with our
Canadian counterparts and they are
rightly because of where we think it's
splashed down I mean they're sort of the
in concert with the U.S Coast Guard but
they are also involved in in trying to
locate the debris right now but there
was good communication with our Canadian
allies signs of a foreign government
taking a special interest in that object
from yesterday not reacting in an
unusual way no
two questions one you mentioned early on
that um
this the the China
balloon might have been giving limited
additive capabilities I assume you're
meeting onto their satellite
surveillance can you specify what I mean
what exactly it's getting from a balloon
that they're not getting from orbiting
satellite instead of Gold Rush like
dozens with the caveat that we haven't
fully recovered everything that we have
recovered some things from the bottom of
the uh of the Atlantic
um and we're analyzing that but with
that caveat that we don't know exactly
uh what this uh balloon uh was
surveilling or what its capabilities
were so just in general and I that's an
important caveat that I'd like you to
remember
um when you are at a lower altitude then
space
um you could perhaps get a better
Fidelity uh of uh of uh of uh of imagery
for instance of things on the ground uh
when you are not moving at the speed of
a satellite and therefore you know only
getting seconds over a a site when you
can maneuver
Left Right Slow Down Speed up like this
thing could then you can loiter if you
can loiter you can soak in a little bit
more you can spend more time over a
sensitive site some of their satellites
are in geostationary or orbit I mean
they're just sitting there Gathering
signals intelligence right so um
what is the benefit I mean is it just to
see what kind of fidelity we're going to
learn more I'd rather not go into any
more detail than that right now we're
going to learn more
um and frankly I think that's a terrific
question you should be asking Beijing
and and one last one of the um you said
that uh before the other object shot
down were not able
to transmit or we're not transmitting
signals that they did not have any
option did the China balloon did that
have any
um was it emitting signals back I'm not
going to go into more detail about uh
the capabilities of that we are going to
be studying it and analyzing it there is
no question in our minds that that
system was designed to surveil that that
was an intelligence asset I'll leave it
there
any Outreach from anywhere in the
administration to the kinds of companies
that produce
weather balloons or other
craft that would fit these descriptions
that might be from the commercial or
corporate world to say is this yours or
any kind of Outreach or have you been
hearing from anyone who might say we
have ours they're in this area is any of
that going on now I don't know of any
conversations right now uh Kelly but one
of the reasons why the president
directed Mr Sullivan to put together an
interagency effort is to take a long
look at that and try to learn a little
bit better about who
is up at that altitude doing what uh for
a completely legitimate purposes I think
we we all recognize we need to probably
have a better side picture on that and
that's why the president wants the
center agency effort to take a look
they're kind of intelligence might be
happening in terms of the diplomacy
that's going on or whatever if these are
state-owned uh
objects I'm not sure I understand what
you mean is there is there a network of
conversations that might be happening
where someone might be able to say based
on this
octagonal description that hey that
sounds like the so-and-so I mean
is there some conversations that are
happening that might be able to give us
some descriptions I mean the short
answer to your question is yes and I
talked about that my opening statement
the President also directed secretary
blank and secretary Austin uh director
Haynes uh to have these kinds of
conversations with our allies and
partners around the world to share with
them what we're learning but also to see
get that get their perspectives we're
quick to say it's ours but it was for
commercial purposes
yeah again we're going to
work we're gonna conversations with our
allies and partners to see what kind of
experiences that they have had what uh
what we can learn from from them what
perhaps they can learn from us deal with
object or can we call them balloons
stool object
I won't mess that up today on the
corporate angle is there any expectation
that this is going to affect the the
executive order on surveilling the U.S
companies and what they're doing in
China and the their I know exactly okay
and then
um is there and just you said a moment
ago that there's no knowledge of a U.S
balloon or other craft over Chinese
territory just being cognizant of the
fact that China has a different
definition of what their territory is
than the United States is there any U.S
surveillance aircraft over Taiwan over
uh the South China Sea that that would
would fit into that there is no U.S
surveillance aircraft uh over Chinese in
Chinese airspace okay even Chinese
claimed airspace you know U.S
surveillance aircraft and Chinese
airspace and then just finally is there
any
um new formal approach that's being
developed as far as how you're going to
deal with these things on a systematic
basis going forward is there well again
I again that's what that's exactly what
the the president wants Mr Sullivan to
run is the process and enter an AC
process to help us as I said in my
opening statement get around the policy
implications here and whether and
whether or not there needs to be any uh
policy changes going forward
um there's no president for U.S Fighters
taking down objects over U.S territories
as far as I'm aware of I guess my
question is
you talked about the The Tweak in the
radar systems yes there's been a tweak
and a threshold for uh the Pentagon uh
presenting to the president president
signing off on military action related
to
to anything over our airspace I'm not
sure I'm following which is
yeah The Radars were tweaked which is
why you think we're seeing some of these
things right has the decision about or
has a threshold for the use of Fighters
to take down objects also been tweaked
because if it lowered has it been
changed we've never seen this before all
of a sudden we've seen no actually I'm
sorry I didn't understand it at first no
I mean and you heard General van Hart
talk about this last night and he's
using established protocols
um to engage
um
the crafting in the air aircraft in the
air
um that can be legitimately brought down
and as he said last night the best way
to do that certainly in a timely and
efficient effective way was through
fighter aircraft and through the
Sidewinder air-to-air missiles and they
looked at and he talked about this they
looked at other options to try to bring
them down to include gunfire but that
would have presented a greater risk to
the pilots themselves so this was the
safest most effective way to do that now
where we go from here I think we just
don't know right now in terms of whether
there needs to be threshold changes as
you put out
I think it's important to just take a
step back here and and remember what the
president did was ordered these actions
with the Safety and Security of the
American people foremost in his mind
um and there were there were very good
reasons to do it
um the military then once given an order
determines how they're going to execute
that order and general van hurt decided
that the best way to do this was with
Sidewinder missiles and fighter aircraft
on it this isn't reactive to the Chinese
Bible in the sense of there was
political pressure and so we are going
to quickly to take down any objects over
our airspace because of the pressure
that came from the Republicans this was
these were decisions based uh purely and
simply on what was in the best interest
of the American people
thanks John
um John does the US government have
video or imagery of these latest
intercepts and will you guys be
releasing it you'd have to talk to DOD
about that Jackie I I don't know what
kind of imagery might exist and uh and
they'd be one to talk about whether
they're releasable or not
um obviously
certainly with respect to the Spy
balloon
we want to make sure that we are
gleaning what we can from this imagery
so that we can answer your questions
better
um and so to what degree there is or
will it will or not be public release I
do want to stress that you know we're
going to want to make sure that we have
had a chance to analyze that imagery uh
for ourselves as much as possible
trying to discern is
is more and I said that could be one
reason why we're finding one reason but
what we're getting at is you know why
are we all of a sudden shooting them
down and
to add to that you know the NORAD
Commander for instance said that uh when
the first spy balloon was crossing over
Americans and Canadian airspace one of
the reasons that he couldn't take action
was because his assessment was that it
didn't pose a military threat or have
hostile intent and so he couldn't take
action there it seems like maybe that
protocol has changed or his his ability
to make that call where there is not an
imminent threat militarily or physically
might have changed it so can you explain
to us
what change why are we shooting them
down all of a sudden I kind of feel like
I took care of that in my opening
statement but I'm happy to revisit it I
mean really two reasons here and these
are
in certainly in
well in both cases they're different I
think we need to separate the Chinese
Bible and we knew what it was
we knew where it was going
we knew what he was trying to do and by
not taking it down I mean it was also
a huge payload like I said the size of
three school buses so really the option
of shooting that down over land wasn't
a legitimate option because somebody
really could have gotten hurt and we
used the the time available to us
knowing what this thing was all about we
used that time to study it to learn from
it to collect on it
then taking it down at the earliest
opportunity in the water and we have
retrieved some of that debris off the
bottom and we're studying that hang on a
second I'll be right there
um but so let's separate that from these
other three and these other three
what are some of the differences
altitude's a big difference
let me let me get through this
the Chinese spy balloon was at 60 000
plus well outside commercial air traffic
uh concerns these three were right on
the border of it so there was a
legitimate concern there
Chinese Bible Moon we knew exactly what
that thing was and we knew what it was
trying to do and we saw it Jackie as it
slowed down sped up maneuvered a little
bit
um trying to get a look at what we
believe to be sent to the military sites
these other three
they didn't have propulsion they weren't
being maneuvered it was basically there
had been being driven uh by the by the
wind
we don't think we don't we don't know
for sure whether they had a surveillance
aspect to them but we can't rule it out
so there was a little bit there was
enough uncertainty there uh that again
out of an abundance of caution doing The
Prudent thing the president directed
that they get taken down and I I get
where you're going is this the standard
going forward and we're gonna we're
gonna dive into this we're going to
learn from these three events
um we're going to continue to study what
happened we're going to have an
interagency effort that helps us get
around the policy implications here and
we'll see where this goes but bottom
line for President Biden is you got to
do the right thing for the American
people for our Safety and Security
is theirs
uh I I can't say whether that's strange
or not since we're sort of in Uncharted
Territory here no pun intended but we
don't you know we don't we don't know
and I suspect that that we
go ahead I'm I'm basically done I'm
basically done sir what's your name sir
from CBS okay um has the payload been
recovered from South Carolina yet
the
payload that's yeah as I said some of
the debris certainly uh they were able
to take things off the surface
like the next day actually that
afternoon uh some of the balloon uh
fabric
um and in the days since they have been
able to recover some not all uh of the
payload that sank to the bottom of the
Atlantic it's about 45 feet of water
weather conditions are pretty tough off
the coast right now like today for
instance they have not been able to get
into the water and dive on it but over
the course of the weekend they were able
to raise some of the debris including uh
some of the electronics and uh in some
of the structure the expectation of when
all that payload is going to be
collected I don't I wish if I if I could
tell you that I'd be a very wealthy man
I mean it's gonna it could take it could
take a long time uh given uh see the sea
State and weather conditions and the
degree to which we have to protect the
safety of the divers one last question
you said you were unsure of the
surveillance capabilities of these
latest objects
um last week we were told several times
that every precaution was taken to
ensure that the sensitive installations
were covered we don't know exactly what
you all did but has there been nor are
you gonna find out
well it has there been a posture change
Nationwide regarding all of these
sensitive uh sites if you're proactively
if you're
um
let me just put a fork in this if this
if if the implication is that you know
uh there's some sort of blanket now
security policy for every base on the
continental United States the answer is
no
we do have protocols particularly when
we we know
um that
um surveillance is going to occur like
in the open Skies tree with Russia for
instance uh when all that's scheduled
and laid out and when you know that
there's going to be an open Skies flight
by uh by Russia you take the appropriate
actions and that's what we did in the
case of the Chinese by balloon and we'll
always do that I will never talk about
what precautions we're going to make at
any given base at any given time but we
always do what we need to do to protect
our nation's secrets I I won't talk
about it any more than that okay
thank you very much okay Admiral
um you started the briefing by talking
about the president's involvement in
this the report from uh Odie and I
recently that that goes over this in
that odni report about unidentified
aerial phenomena it says there were 247
unidentified aerial phenomenon reports
since March of 2021. some of which have
quote demonstrated unusual flight
characteristics or performance
capabilities so can you say why the
president
just recently within the last couple
weeks started ordering some of these
objects to be shot down and why there
weren't any orders throughout 2021 or
throughout 2022. it's very it's very
simple it comes down to what sort of
Safety and Security threats and risk
we're talking about
um and uh and also
uh it comes down to a lot to our ability
to attract to track detect and engage
having come from the Pentagon I can tell
you that some of these uaps
while we may not be able to know what
each and every one is doing
some of the big concern there was that
um a lot not many of those reports were
happening around our training ranges
were happening around
air training ranges so combat Pilots
were seeing these things and it was and
there was a potential impact to the
safety of flight of our Pilots but you
may not have but a fleeting moment on
some of these things to to see it and so
it's different in these cases
um we had time to detect time to analyze
time to engage time to make those kinds
of decisions but it all comes down to
Safety and Security first and foremost
the time though is a matter of
capability you have better capabilities
now than we did we are certainly
improving our capabilities now and and
as I said the president has directed The
National Security team uh to dig into
this deeper from an interancy effort and
to see what uh if other uh improvements
might need to make I mean look just
just by adapting the way the radar
parameters are set
we have improved our ability to detect
and again I said that could be one
reason why we're seeing more
um so you said that the debris fell on
Frozen Waters or in remote areas and
these are also like huge objects and
they were shot down by Nissan so how
optimistic are you that you will be able
to collect enough debris to really get
an idea of what these objects were
we won't know until we get on site to
see
um you know how much damage was done not
just by uh the missile strike but by the
fall from from a very high altitude and
as you said in one case on sea ice
um so we'll just have to see
yeah uh thank you John the Secretary of
State Lincoln planned to meet with this
Chinese counterpart this week at the
Munich security conference I'm referring
to the state department for the
secretary's schedule I I don't have
visibility on that okay and
um have you been able to what have you
been able to learn more uh or not you
but the government since these uh
objects were shot down I mean you you
just alluded to the fact that uh that
not being able to get on site yet I mean
has there been any additional
information since one was shot down
Friday and then over the weekend
because these are just happened over the
last few days and we haven't found the
debris
um there's uh there's still a lot more
we expect to be able to learn and I
think once we can get to the debris and
I'm not forecasting how easy that's
going to be they all three have fallen
uh into some pretty remote uh difficult
areas to reach but we're going to do
everything we can to find them and that
will tell us a lot since we have since I
know you didn't ask about this but uh in
the case of the Chinese spy balloon we
have been able to recover some debris
and some of the electronics uh and even
some of the structure from the bottom of
the Atlantic and that will also tell us
a lot and we are uh we're learning from
it right now
everybody
as much debris as you can get from all
the sites I'm sorry when do we think
when do you think we'll be satisfied
that you've gotten as much debris as you
can from all the sites I wish I could
give you a date certain on the calendar
I can't do that we're gonna we're we're
into surveil them right now in fact you
know there's a uh an adp3 that's flying
over the site in Alaska the Canadians
are in charge obviously of the one in
the Yukon and now the Coast Guard is in
the Lake Huron working with the Canadian
Coast Guard to do the same thing uh
there so we're working this as hard as
we can and we will keep you informed as
we learn more as I'm joined today divers
in the water over the weekend we have
recovered debris off the coast of uh of
South Carolina we'll keep you informed
brief Congress this week there have been
briefings as early as late last week and
we do fully expect that there will be
additional briefings this week perhaps
even perhaps even later today
we're running out of time discussions
response they've been very harsh they
said the first balloon was an accident
in the last three objects were not there
have you respond to that has the White
House had conversations with Beijing
about this you can share a little bit
about that we know the first one was
Chinese they admitted it they claimed it
was a weather balloon we know it's not
these three we don't have attribution
for right now we don't know we don't
know who owns them
um so I'm not going to take anybody's
word at face value here until we can get
a chance to to take a look at them are
we in touch with the Chinese
um uh we have we have an embassy in
Beijing we maintain routine diplomatic
conversations and we have had uh in over
that spyballoon incident we did have uh
private discussions with senior Chinese
leaders okay
I'm not aware of any plans for that just
ask a question on Israel does the
president plan to speak with PM
Netanyahu about the moves his government
is making to try to weaken the Israel I
have no calls or conversations to read
out
um uh but we are deeply concerned by
some of the moves here with respect to
settlements
[Music]
just recently has said that there was a
Russian plot to sort of overthrow her
government and break moldova's path to
Europe it was something that President
zielinski himself had also warned about
what is the U.S assessment of this
possible a plot and more broadly what is
the concern about Russia's attempts to
sort of influence these these
pro-european governments in the region
even though it's right now focused on
Ukraine about other countries in the
region
so um
what I'll say about that is uh deeply
concerning reports certainly
not outside the bounds of Russian
behavior and we absolutely stand with
the moldovan government and the moldovan
people we have no confirmation from the
U.S side of I know no independent
confirmation but we're certainly not
questioning the capacity the will of the
of the Russians of Mr Putin to try to do
that is perfectly right a page I ran out
of his Playbook
yes I I was going to ask you a question
just one quick question that these are
lighter than air or heavier than air we
have not okay but we have to get to
everyone okay you already had a question
okay
um all three shoot Downs in the US
occurred offshore but the one in Canada
occurred over land so is it effective
U.S policy to not shoot down these
objects over land for safety concerns I
wouldn't read it into this some kind of
policy decision we will always in
deciding whether something should be
taken down or not consider the impact on
the ground
the Chinese uh
the Chinese foreign Ministry indicated
they would respond in a way that they
were prepared to if it turns out that
the other objects are also Chinese in
origin is the is there a menu of options
prepared for the president for how we
would react terrific hypothetical we're
just not there yet yeah so I realized a
relationship issue you have the Chinese
spy Airship that went through you've got
China and buy more oil from Russia
you've got China uh
opening up cases in the US trying to
steal U.S technology from universities
another president she is going to be
meeting with the Iranian president at
what point do you review a big review of
the U.S relationship with China and at
one point does the president ask for a
call from president XI
again I don't have a call to talk about
today let me just again level said here
and I know I'm running close on time but
uh sorry uh but the the president met
with President XI at Bali at the G20 the
whole purpose of that discussion was to
move this relationship forward in a
better way most consequential bilateral
relationship in the world the president
knows that and he wanted to move that
relationship forward uh in a better way
and secretary blinken was dang near
wheels up trying to head to Beijing to
have those kinds of conversations to get
some of these communication vehicles and
venues back on track whether it's
climate change or military to military
we were willing to do that we were
looking forward to doing that and then
the Chinese decided to fly a
surveillance balloon over the
continental United States and it
wouldn't be inappropriate to have that
meeting when when are those discussions
going to get back on the calendar I
couldn't tell you as you as secretary
blinken has said it'll happen at the at
the appropriate time now is not that
time it doesn't mean and people
shouldn't take away from this that all
communication has been severed between
the United States and China that Beijing
and Washington aren't talking we still
have an embassy there we still have
an ability through secretary blinken's
good offices to communicate with senior
Chinese leaders unfortunately the
Chinese military is not interested in
talking to secretary uh Secretary of
Defense Austin but but there are still
ways to to communicate and the president
would tell you that now's exactly the
time to at least preserve some of those
lines of communication so that we can
avoid miscalculation I haven't set back
the relationship
let's learn has this all this list of
things set back to relationship it is
certainly not helped us move forward in
the way that we want it to move right
last question about thing that's gonna
be the last question
no sir
right here James okay oh thank you
last Friday you answered my question
about President Biden's message during
his trip to Poland but I'm wondering why
he specifically chosen Poland for this
trip since so many countries are helping
Ukraine and he visited Poland 11 months
ago
the president's really looking forward
to this trip
um certainly
not lost I'm sure on any of you that
it's time to round what's sadly is going
to be a year of war in Ukraine
um Poland has been
a strident Ally a tremendous supporter
of of Ukraine
um and a generous host not only to
American troops but millions of
Ukrainian refugees uh who have fled
there in safety
um the the polls are pardoned upon but
they're punching well above their weight
and and uh and we very much appreciate
all the support the president wants to
thank president Duda in person he wants
to thank the Polish people in person he
wants to make broader points about how
it's important for the kind of courage
and unity we're seeing out of Poland and
so many NATO allies continues uh sadly
into what will now be a second year of
War
okay thank you very much
one on the
um unexplained aerial phenomenal
uh and the second will be on the Russian
Ukraine war
um
my understanding is that the top
officials of the Pentagon when asked
explicitly if they were ruling out any
kind of extraterrestrial presence that
they weren't ruling anything out and yet
at the beginning of today's briefing
albeit with your usual winning smile uh
Ms Jean-Pierre seemed to rule out any
extraterrestrial activity I don't think
the American people need to worry about
aliens and
I think there's any more that needs to
be said there on the Russia Ukraine war
as we approached the anniversary
in the days immediately after the
commencement of the conflict we heard
from senior U.S officials such as the
CIA director in the Congressional
testimonial that President Putin had
been observed by U.S officials to have
constricted his decision-making Circle
during the pandemic that he was making
erratic decisions and these were seen to
have played out in in what happened on
the battlefield
as we approach this year anniversary
what do we observe about President
Putin's decision making now the caliber
of his decision making and also his grip
on power in his own country has any of
that changed over the course of the year
I can't speak to the way Mr Putin gets
advised and how he
you know who's advising him and what
they're saying I I couldn't begin to get
inside uh Kremlin decision-making
process he's
clearly Mr Putin is not making good
decisions shouldn't have invaded in the
first place this is a country that posed
no threat to anybody let alone Russia
clearly he hasn't made sound decisions
nor has his military with respect to
their performance on the battlefield
they're still suffering some of the same
problems they were a year ago Logistics
sustainment integration of joint uh
fires uh Manpower Personnel unit
cohesion I could go on and on the
Russian military is still struggling
they they have not surmounted these
these problems and it's borne out by the
fact that you know he continues to
change generals the way I change socks
so I mean he's he's still struggling
yeah that's right guys we have to end
the briefing
um I gotta go into the oval but um I
will see you tomorrow and thank you for
the compliment on the smile I appreciate
that but I'll be well I'll be back
tomorrow thanks everybody